alright so put your hands together for
our team 16 hi I'm Ted and this is
kelsey and we are the hands on team
projects team also known as hot projects
ok so our problem is very basic we have
a lot of all over the world communities
that don't have resources and who lack
hands-on education and learning
opportunities and also in these
communities in every community you're
always going to find problems that
affect your self or quality of life so
we want to see what these what would
happen if students tried to solve these
problems so our goal is to empower young
people in developing countries and low
resource communities to recognize
problems in their community and actually
address them to tackle them head-on and
we're going to be providing a valuable
learning experience that they can't get
from a traditional classroom setting ok
so we have a little bit strawberry for
you so first the students are
identifying a problem in their community
so this case they need to cross a stream
in order to go home all right so we're
going to pair them with a trained
facilitator as well as a they're gonna
have access to a dedicated space
equipped with an internet-connected
computer and a basic makerspace with
construction tools and materials and
then they're going to do background
research on their problem and in their
community we're giving them a web
platforms they can look online see what
other teams have done in the past
document their project as they're going
along and and share their projects get
feedback from other students elsewhere
and be connected with resources and then
they're going to use what they've
learned through their internet research
and by applying the education that
they've had so far to solve this problem
so in this case they're trying to build
a foot bridge over the river sometimes
they'll fail they'll learn to deal with
failure to learn from their mistakes and
also they're using resources found in
their community and the students will
eventually find an effective solution
after trial and error
and then students can help lay their
students to fund projects to identify
challenges and we work with other
organizations to do this how do you
surpass the trial and error continuation
out you actually incentive it to keep on
trying so from the beginning we want the
students choosing projects that they're
passionate about so we want to go
through a process not just a
brainstorming coming up with something
and starting to work on it but actually
convincingly enthusiastic and interested
in solving the problem so for example if
they're fixing open gutters or there's a
stream in front of their house things
across or there's fly infestation or if
it's um there's not enough lighting or
these are gonna be problems that are
important to them to people in their
community but but it will supervise that
so the facilitator is going to we're
thinking to recruit recent college grads
they can do it as a service with a small
stipend kind of like Teach for America
or teach parade yet okay I'm afraid but
so uh we're talking about having a
nonprofit organization so we would
require require funding but we're
working with minimal infrastructure and
we're not hiring a professional we're
hiring someone just out of college in
India where we're planning to pilot this
there is no lack of recent college grads
who are looking for jobs
because how do you get beyond the trial
and error method I love those yeah they
have an incentive to want to do better
because it affects their boyfriend it's
not just trial near there they have
access to too fast online resources and
people to guide them and accessing those
resources to previous projects but you
know to Wikipedia to Google so it's not
it's not just trial and error that they
wouldn't they would actually benefit
from everyone else's experience from
instructables for example in an any
great learning experience in any great
process when you're doing scary you're
gonna fail under go where that's so
great